>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, D.C.
>> Letters About Literature
is a special project
of the Center for the Book.
It's about years old.
I'm about to introduce Cathy
Gourley, who is the coordinator
of the project and she'll
tell you a little bit
about how today's project works
and then when we will meet three
of the winners from the states.
It's a project that from the
beginning has asked young people
to write to authors about books
that have helped shape their lives
or helped change the way that
they think about themselves.
And the project had a beginning
of around 18 years ago
with Cathy and myself.
Cathy has been a consultation
for the Center
for the Book for many years.
And we started with Read
Magazine where Cathy was an editor
and gradually as Cathy will
explain to you the nature of Letters
About Literature has changed and
it's actually broadened in scope
and Target has become our primary
sponsor, our major retail sponsor
and that support has
enabled us to tie Letters
About Literature to
the state centers.
There are centers for the book
in every state and Letters
About Literature is a project
that we not only offer to them
with support from target but
also want them to encourage --
encourage them to use as a basis
for reading promotion
throughout the states.
Many of you saw the state
centers who are really
with the state libraries, dominate
our pavilion of the states.
So this is an example of a project
that is truly national and is one
of the projects that helps make
really the national testable
of the book, something
that is truly national.
And so I think it's appropriate
that we conclude this,
the 10th anniversary of the
National Book Festival with hearing
from the young people and delving
right into the heart of one
of our most popular projects.
I would Cathy Gourely
who is our coordinator
to say a few words
about the project.
And she can explain to you how
it's changed its educational tone.
Then we will meet the families,
hear from the kids and also hear
from the authors to whom two of
the letters were written this year.
Cathy. [Applause]
>> Cathy Gourely: Okay
you've got mail.
That's an understatement for me.
Each year in December the
post office delivers mail bins
by the dozens filled with
letters and they come from all
across the country and they
come from children as young as 9
and 10 years old and seniors
in high school as well.
And these letters are very personal.
They're not writing to me,
but I get to read them.
Letters About Literature started
out as a program called Books
Changing Lives, but it kind evolved
into a personal conversation
with an author.
Here's what we do.
We ask kids, we challenge kids,
write a letter to an author,
living or dead, that's okay.
Tell that author how his or her
work somehow changed your view
of yourself or your world.
We say, "Don't summarize the book."
Why? The author wrote the book.
So the author knows
what the book is about.
What the author doesn't know
is how the book touched you.
The author doesn't know
what emotions you felt
when you were reading the book or
what thoughts entered your head
after you finished reading the book.
Write about that.
Read the book.
Get inspired and write back.
Well, our kids do not disappoint us.
This year we received
70,000 letters.
In fact, I learned
new post office lingo.
The mail bins came in a device
called an erk, which is as kind
of big as a refrigerator
and it's filled up higher
than my head with bins of mail.
My team and I begin
to open the letters.
We count them.
We log them and then
we begin to read them.
And we eliminated in the first two
rounds of reading, 63,000 letters.
So only 7,000 letters nationally
advance to state competition,
just to advance to
state is a big deal.
So what happens next?
Okay, so the state judges
now read their state letters
and they choose their state winners.
And we have three state
winners with you here today.
So we've gone from 70,000
to about 7,000 to about 150.
And then those letters go
on to national competition
and the national winners,
we pick 6, that's all.
So 70,000 to 7,000 to 150 to 6, and
we also pick 12 national honors.
But here's the big deal.
The national honors and the national
winners, they earn in addition
to cash prizes, they earn a reading
promotion grant for the library.
The 6 national winners each
earn 10,000 dollars for a school
or a library, but they get
to nominate the school.
And I'm just about done, but
in Anchorage this year, Alaska,
they had their very first
ever national winner.
She was junior in high school.
And what she did was, she did not
nominate her high school library.
She said to us, "I want to give this
money, 10,000 dollars to a school
that needs it perhaps more
than my high school does."
And she gave it to
an elementary school
in Anchorage that was in need.
And that principal didn't know her.
The librarian didn't know her.
So the kids know.
They get it.
And they're very altruistic.
So with that aside, I'm going
to turn this back over to John.
He's going to introduce
each of our three winners
that we've invited here today.
They are guest authors and
they're going to read their letters
and they are going to have
a very unique opportunity
of meeting their author and having
the author answer their letter
in person.
>> John: Thank you Cathy.
[Applause] First however I would
like to know if anyone is still here
from Target, I want to
thank you personally
for the support that
you've given us.
Let's give Target a hand.
[Applause] Target of course is the
major sponsor the Book Festival
and they have been here today
but when the person we work
with most closely did not make the
trip to Washington but she knows
about this and we were
hoping that some
of the other folks could be here.
But I heard that they also are
packing up now and are on their way
out but they know that we are here
and they know that we are grateful.
I would like to mention that
I'm going to introduce everyone
that is going to participate in
this and then it's on with the show.
If you were here you already
know Katherine Paterson.
Katherine is our of
course National Ambassador
for Young People's Literature.
The award-winning Katherine
Paterson and you are here
to learn why Katherine is the
National Ambassador if you sat
through the marvelous session
she gave us earlier today.
She also is the write and producer
of the Exquisite Corpse
Family Theater in which
in the first session
in the children's division we
brought the successful online serial
story to almost a conclusion.
Only part of it -- the
story is concluded,
but next year it's
going to be a book.
So the Exquisite is
never going to end.
And Katherine we're glad of that
and we're glad to have you here.
The second author
that is participating was here
earlier this afternoon and is
with us again, Michael Buckley,
who's a former television
producer who's now into the world
of children's literature
and children's books,
particularly through The
Sisters Grimm and we're going
to guess what -- have
a letter to Michael
as the author of Sisters Grimm.
Our three students are with us
today and the first one who is going
to read is Olivia Marcantonio.
Olivia is actually -- maybe we're
not going to start quite yet.
We're going to wait just a moment.
I'm going to introduce
you and then you're going
to be up in just a moment.
And Olivia is level one in
the Letters About Literature.
She was 11 when she
wrote this letter.
She's 12 years now and her letter
is written to Jerry Spinelli
and it describes the book Star Girl.
And Olivia now is with her family
and I know her mother is here
from Great Falls is that correct.
Our second student -- and
Olivia then is the one
that represents Virginia.
Our Maryland representative
who since has moved
to Virginia I learned
today is Claire Wang
and Claire is level two,
which is grade 7 and 8.
Claire wrote this letter.
I think you're 14 now?
Tell me, correct me please.
You're 14 now.
Okay thank you.
And she wrote to Katherine
Paterson and her letter is
about the Bridge to Terabithia.
And we are very pleased
to have Claire here.
The final winner is going to be
Katherine Ann VanKirk who is 13
and she is the on who wrote to
Michael Buckley and she is --
we're delighted to
have Katherine here.
She is from Washington,
D.C. So these are representatives
of our states.
And now Olivia it's your turn to
come on up and read your letter.
Let's give Olivia Marcantonio
a big hand.
[ Sound effects ]
>> Olivia Marcantonio:
Dear Mr. Jerry Spinelli:
Star Girl was one of those books.
I don't know how else
to describe it.
It is a book that completely
turns you inside out.
Many books deal with a
character who is different,
but none of those characters
actually enjoys being different.
Star Girl showed me not to change,
to be my definition of normal,
to be myself, as long as that self
does not have a negative effect
on other people.
This book surprised me.
By reading it, I discovered
things about myself
that I never noticed before.
I discovered my strengths in
the characters of Star Girl.
Like her, I don't pay attention
to negative peer pressure.
I discovered my weaknesses
in Hillary's character.
I am often determined to
dislike certain people.
You should care about what other
people think of you, but not as much
as you should care how you
make other people feel.
We are the main character in our
own story, but it never occurs to us
that we might be the bad
guy in someone else's.
By reading Star Girl I stopped
seeing everyone else as "Them",
with a capital "T" and started
seeing people as individuals.
While everyone is made from
the same primary colors,
it's how we mix those colors
to create ourselves
that makes us different.
Now I fully recognize that you
can't treat everyone the same way.
What resolves an argument
in one person may insight an
argument in a different person.
I never knew that before.
I have learned to accept other's
differences by reading Star Girl.
Not necessarily big differences,
not even important differences.
It could be something as
small and inconsequential
as liking a book series
that I happen to hate.
Then again a person might
dislike me because of that.
I've learned to accept that too.
I have learned to tolerate
people when the opinion
of everyone else strongly
contradicts my own.
Mr. Spinelli, before I read
Star Girl I was the same kind
of different that I am now.
I always speak my opinion,
good or bad, hurtful or not.
Now though, you and
Star Girl have taught me
that while being different is
good, I have to keep it in control
like a bush, in some places you let
it grow and in others you prune it
down so it doesn't stick out into
the neighbor's yard and annoy them.
Mr. Spinelli, you taught me how
to be normal without changing,
to change my image while the
way I think stays the same,
to be myself without hurting others.
Thank you.
>> John: Thank you Olivia.
[Applause] Now Olivia stay
here for just a second.
Jerry Spinelli was invited to the
Book Festival but could not make it.
And we were able however just a
couple of days ago to get in touch
with him and Cathy had
sent the letter to him
through is publicist
and he has read it.
And the night before last I
got the following response
from Jerry Spinelli and for just
a second, you're going to have
to pretend like I'm
Jerry Spinelli okay.
[Laughter] This is what he said.
"No Olivia, thank you.
Thank you for being the dream
reader we writers all wish for,
someone who takes from the story
not only what we put in but even,
maybe even a little more.
Thank you Olivia for making
a story a part of your life
and thereby affirming something
the poet, Murial Rukeyser wrote,
"The world is not made
of atoms but of stories."
And thank you Olivia for confirming
my own belief as an author
that a book is only half done until
someone picks it up and reads it.
So you'll understand if I
think of you as my co-author.
Best wishes from Star Girl
and me, Jerry Spinelli."
And I'll send you a
copy of the email.
>> Cathy Gourley: And I like
to present you with a tee shirt
that says, "I cannot
live without books."
And a writing journal that matches,
because we want you to keep writing;
at 11 years old what a great job.
[Applause] And I now would like
to invite Claire to come up
and read her letter
and I did not mention
that Claire is a home-schooler
and also to invite both Katherine
and Michael to come up
and take these stools
and we will have two consecutive
readings and then comments.
[ Sound effects ]
>> Claire Wang: Dear
Katherine Paterson:
What brings two completely
different people together
and creates a lasting
bond between them.
In what ways does it
change our lives forever?
To me a friendship seems
useless and superficial.
I believe that something or someone
will always break it or destroy it,
erase it with no trace at all.
When my family moved back to
Beijing, I lost all my best friends.
Year's worth of friendship was
broken in a matter of minutes.
I became bitter and cautious
to any potential companions.
In a Chinese public school
I was known as the tall,
think Chinese-American girl
who had no feelings at all.
However I was indifferent
to the gossip around me.
The hurtful gossip
further proved my point.
Thankfully my parents transferred
me to a bilingual private school.
Slowly but surely I became attached
to some of the people there.
In that group of people
was a girl named Vicki.
Her attitude and characteristics
were similar
to your character Leslie
Burke, bright and lively,
bold and somewhat rebellious.
We helped with each
other's struggles.
She was a leader and
I was a follower.
Regardless of our completely
different personalities Vicki
and I were soon best friends.
Although my parents
started to home-school me,
things remained the same between us.
I thought I will always
see her again.
One cloudy day, someone
told me the shocking news.
"Vicki's dead."
I felt stunned and
helpless that entire day.
A car accident took her bright life.
Again, a perfect friendship was
destroyed in a matter of minutes.
Again, I became bitter.
Never again should I
ever rely on friendship.
ever have a close friend.
I repeated these promises to
myself almost every night.
As books are one of my
escapes from the real world,
I picked up the book Bridge to
Terabithia from my dusty bookshelf.
Although I read Bridge
to Terabithia before,
I felt something different
this time.
I understood Jess Aaron's feelings
before Leslie came into his life.
I smiled at the adventures
that Jess and Leslie had
in their magical world
of Terabithia.
I thought that their perfect
friendship would go on forever.
I was shocked when Brenda
told Jess that Leslie is dead.
That part is like a clear
reflection of my present situation.
However, I was curious to see
how Jess reacted to this event.
When I finished your book, I
knew immediately what to do.
Just like Jess who passed down the
lessons that Leslie taught him,
I will try to do the same.
I will remember how Vicki impacted
others through her cheerful,
creative spirit and
strong leadership.
Instead of being timid and
shy, I will try to help others
with my leadership and smile to
pass down the gift Vicki left me.
I used to think that death marked
an ending, however now I know
that it also marks a new
beginning for a new friendship.
Thank you so much for teaching
me this valuable lesson
through your book.
Thank you for making me understand
how God intended friendship to be.
Sincerely, Claire Wang.
[ Sound effects ]
>> Thank you Claire.
That was wonderful.
>> Claire Wang: Thank you.
>> John: We're going to have
Katherine give you a response.
She needs to calm down a bit.
>> Katherine Paterson:
I need to calm down.
>> Claire Wang: Thank you.
[ Sound effects ]
>> John: And now I'd like
Katherine, Katherine Ann VanKirk
to read here letter
to Michael Buckley
and then we will hear
from both authors.
[ Sound effects ]
>> Katherine Ann VanKirk:
Dear Mr. Michael Buckley:
I would like to tell you about how
your series The Sisters Grimm helped
me, but first I think you should
know a little bit about me.
I am 12 years old, now 13.
[Laughter] My parents are divorced.
When you think about a divorce
you picture two people fighting
and then them getting separated.
Then everything becomes fine.
This is not reality.
I am part of a Lunch Bunch
group that is designed
to help kids with problems at home.
I'm the only kid there with divorced
parents and I'm not the only kid
in the group that has
separated parents.
This reality makes me feel even
worse about what happens at home.
Amongst all this is my
little sister Caroline.
I don't have a great
relationship with my sister.
I mean its okay but
it's not the kind
of relationship I would
have wished for.
Now that you know a bit about
me, I would like to tell you
about how I started reading books.
The first time I read your
book was in the spring
of 5th grade, about two years ago.
I finished a book and I was
looking for another one.
I asked my librarian and she gave me
your fourth book, Once Upon a Curse.
I had no idea that
it was in a series.
Of course, I had a few
questions, but I dropped them.
One early Wednesday morning, I was
in SSR, Sustained Silent Reading
and I found that I didn't
have a book to read.
So I decided to look on the cart of
books that was there for us to read.
And I found the first book in the
series, The Fairytale Detectives.
I was surprised because
I had absolutely no idea.
Anyway I checked it out and read it.
It was just as good the
fourth book had been.
I continued to read books
two, three and four again.
Before school one morning
I went to see
if they had book number
five and they didn't.
I continued to look for it,
but I just couldn't find it.
While I was trying to find the
fifth book, I began to think
about the characters in the series.
I thought about how the
two sisters get along
and have a blast without
their parents.
I realized that these sisters
had a strong enough bond
that it didn't make too
bad of an impact on them.
I also began to think about this
could be similar in my life.
If I had a better relationship
with my sister we could work
through what happens and I
wouldn't have to hold it in until
that once a month Lunch Bunch.
I knew what I wanted to do.
I wanted to make the relationship
I had with my sister better.
The only problem was
how would I do it?
I began to brainstorm some ideas
of how I could accomplish this.
I noted that Sabrina and Daphne
spend a lot of time together.
Caroline and I spent time together,
but nearly as much as they did.
I decided to spend
more time with her.
After about two weeks had
past I began to notice
that we were treating
each other differently.
As time went by we
got closer and closer.
It was great, but problems
still came up.
There was no way we could prevent
this but we talked everything
at SM's, secret meetings.
During an SM we would talk
about what was bothering us
and what we would do to change it.
These meetings were like
my Lunch Bunch meetings
but they were private
and overall better.
Now I feel like I could get
through anything with my sister.
I never dreamed of having
a relationship this strong.
I want to thank you for
writing this series.
One thing, which I think you'll
happy to hear is that last weekend,
well not last weekend but you know,
I found book number five and six.
Sincerely, Katherine Ann Vankirk.
[Applause]
>> John: You want to go first.
>> Katherine Paterson: I asked
John Ko to give me a minute
because I think all of us were
deeply moved by Claire's letter.
And I didn't have Jerry
Spinelli's advantage
of seeing the letter first.
I heard it when you heard it.
I think the thing that struck
me in your letter Claire,
was how important friendship is.
And I know in my life I've
had to move many times
and have left behind friends
that I thought I could
not bear to live without.
And I've lost friends who
have died, and at my age more
and more of my friends are dying.
And I think what I've
learned through that
and I think what you've learned
through that is how
precious friendship is.
And that the fact that we've had
those wonderful friendships makes it
possible for us to reach
out to other people in a way
that we couldn't have
without those friendships.
And I'm very grateful that
that's what you learned
from reading Bridge to Terabithia.
You know I always say that the
writer doesn't have a right
to tell the reader what
to take from a book.
And your teacher doesn't
have a right
to tell you what to
take from a book.
No one has a right to tell you
what the book should mean to you.
But it makes me very happy
to know that what you learned
from that book is how
precious friendship was
and that you could never
turn your back on that.
So thanks so much for your letter.
[Applause]
>> Michael Buckley: Katherine I am
a little choked up by your letter
and that's not good
because I'm 6' 3"
and people laugh at
you when you cry.
[Laughter] One of the
things I set out to do
with The Sisters Grimm was tell
a very simple message and that is
that the real magic in the
world doesn't come from wizards
and magic wands, it
comes from family.
And of all the people who
have written me letters,
you seem to get that the best.
I'm glad that the book has had a
positive impact on your relationship
with your sister and hopefully you
can carry that into your adult life.
Because as you get older
you'll hear time and time again
that you can pick your friends
but you cannot pick your family.
But the true magic of a family is
that everyone is a
little bit different,
but they all come together
to form one amazing group.
I'm very happy that you get that.
The one thing I would like
to say is I get many letters
from kids who enjoy the books.
I never thought that anybody would
even read my book when I wrote it,
let alone write me
a letter about it.
And it's truly a special treat.
I think that when a writer sits
down, well at least some of us,
when we sit down we
dream that we're going
to write the next Harry Potter, the
next Wimpy Kid and we're just going
to be swimming in money
like Scrooge McDuck.
[Laughter] But as you go on
in your career as a writer,
at least what I've come across
is that the real treasures to me,
the real reward of what I
do is fans like you who seem
to understand me even better
than I understand myself.
So thank you so much for putting
such time and effort into it
and I truly hope that your sister
has stopped being such a jerk.
[Laughter] Thank you!
>> John: And Cathy and I on behalf
of Letters About Literature wish
to thank both Katherine and
Michael, but especially Olivia,
Claire and Katherine Ann for your
wonderful letters, for being part
of the sharing experience that
we've had about important books
that not only make a difference
but of course, are true letters
about literature that affect
people and their lives
and also have an effect on
the authors and we just --
I would like to call for a round of
applause for all five experiment --
all five people in this
wonderful experiment.
[Applause] And now to close things
for this year's National
Book Festival,
I'm pleased to introduce
Dianna Marham
who is the associate
librarian for library services
and for our purposes Dianna
is actually the director
of the National Book
Festival Planning Team
and if anyone deserves a round of
applause, Dianna really deserves it.
[Applause] Dianna.
>> Dianna Markham: Thank you John.
Thank you Cathy, thank you
authors, thank you writes.
This has been an absolutely
wonderful day for all of us
and I can't stop without
giving these wonderful Letters
About Literature one
more round of applause.
[Applause] They were terrific.
And even though it's hot
at least it's been sunny.
We haven't had to endure rain.
We're all very happy.
And so we end this brilliant
day on a singularly happy note.
We have come at last to the close
of the 10th annual Book Festival.
A fitting conclusion to
this delightful celebration
of the good things
books do for all of us.
I'd like you to look
around at the young people
who are in this room today.
When I see them and I see the
festive characters who were
in our poster, and I see that
young people are connecting
to these characters and to authors
I think back upon my own young life
when I was growing up on
a farm I southern Indiana.
And the best thing for me was going
to the public library on Saturday.
We went to the grocery
store on Saturday
and while my parents bought
groceries we were dropped off
at the public library.
There is nothing that
compares to the discovery
of books in the public library.
And everyone here has had
that same kind of delight,
the freedom to take an amazing
journey that costs you no more time
than it takes you to go
to your school library
or your public library or the
bookstore and pick out a book.
And it's just a marvelous
testament to the power of books
to hear what those individual
books meant in your lives.
And I think all of us
who love books have had
that same kind of experience.
Now it's true that you don't always
have to go to the library anymore.
You can download books
to your Kindle.
from your public library.
But you know you can't have an
author sign the Kindle book.
[Laughter] And there's
something magical
in having the author
sign that book too.
I think we all want to give the
authors a special round of applause.
[Applause] So this is
the 10th anniversary
of the National Book Festival
and we chose the theme:
A Decade of Words and Wonder.
And it is the words that
bring us the wonder.
Good writers pave the
way for avid readers.
Good readers often
become good writers.
Books are the links of
a chain of knowledge
and enjoyment that never ends.
So all of you in this room please
keep reading, keep writing.
Thank you for joining us today
and let's go on to the next decade
of the National Book Festival.
We'll see you again
right here next year.
And until then, best wishes.
Thank you very much.
[Applause]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at www.loc.gov.